We go back to our overall master diagram.
What we have is a driver's script which in this case was just the c program.
We have a random test case generator which is basically two lines of code--one of them
we had computed that used a random number to compute the number of bytes to read
and the other one, actually called the read function.
The software under test was the other function--the read all function that we wrote.
The oracle was implemented by memory comparison function--that is to say
did the read all command actually read the right bytes from a file--and so as we saw,
the oracle never detect an error since we got the function right and everything work out.
This case of implementing a read all call which is stand in for read that behaves better.
It has been on my mind lately because I assigned this is as one problem on the final exam
for my operating systems class that my students finished a couple of weeks ago.
And it turned out that many of the students didn't implement the right code.
A lot of times they forgot in the read all command, for example, to increment buffer so that
subsequent calls to read wouldn't overwrite the original call to read.
I saw so many of those that I decided I write the function myself and see if it was hard,
and it was a little bit tricky but it worked out and that's why I thought it might
make a good example for you all.